the first time I'm actually looking at  the new hundred they did you got the  watermark obviously it's a different one  then you got color shifting here for the  hundred as well there's still the the  raised ink printing you still got those  are forbidden fonts for the serial  number as well there's the security  strip there the polymer security strip  and that is new thing there it's  actually a hologram strip printed over  yeah this is their newer stuff they're  they're different  I wouldn't say more advant advantage  there's many things that could be done  that even I couldn't duplicate and I  know where those are I know it's a that  would stop me dead in my tracks it looks  nice still very easy to do I would not  but it would be nothing for me to do  [Music]